[Music]
on this veterans day we asked a group of
children to share words expressing their
gratitude to americans who have served
in the military this sixth grade class
in clifton virginia took the time to
craft some very heartfelt letters
showing their appreciation to previous
generations of service members those
letters are being read by veterans of
world war ii korea and vietnam who visit
the nation's capital as part of the
honor flight network the program brings
them to washington to see the memorials
built in honor of their service and
their sacrifice
[Music]
dear veteran dear veteran dear veterans
thank you for your service and support
benjamin wrote me a letter and he said
dear veteran thank you for your service
we appreciate your great and honorable
sacrifice you have performed a proud and
honorable duty and sacrificed in a way
that few in this present generation can
understand or appreciate
that's powerful
i'm so proud of you
keep being amazing
heart heart heart heart heart heart
i like hearts
i know it must have been scary at times
but you kept staying strong and i'll be
forever grateful for that thank you for
fighting for a country you're an angel
from god i know it's hard to lose a
friend and it was hard to keep fighting
for our country i can't think or imagine
what it would be like to be away from
your family and friends for a long
period of time
it starts out you are awesome
thank you for not giving up even when
all seems lost for being strong even
when you might feel weak you have given
your life and dedication towards america
you are a strong brave hero and i thank
you with all my heart i can't imagine
what you have gone through you will
never forget what you have done with our
country ever
america would never be the same if it
weren't for you and what you have done
thank you for shaping america into what
it is today and thank you for giving all
your blood sweat and tears for our
country every day we raise the flag
every day we say the pledge of
allegiance
i think it's sad that it's not every day
we honor wonderful people like you
yes we have memorials but we don't
always say thank you in words like a
letter or card like this
thank you i hope after everything you've
done for our country you will live a
long and happy life i am unbelievably
proud of your service
you are one of many soldiers that helped
lead our country to freedom
you will be honored and known for your
great and unselfish sacrifice
our country would not be the same
without you veterans all of the veterans
out there are all heroes
i hope you enjoy your flight to
washington dc the memorial is really
beautiful i hope you like it as much as
i do
sincerely benjamin yeah hannah flynn
paul
maddy many thank yous
memory
thank you very much ella and very thanks
to you sweetheart this is a great letter
and
makes me feel really good i want to tell
benjamin he's going to have a good life
if you see a veteran on the street just
say hello
it's a wonderful experience for any of
us
and it's very memorable i'm not used to
getting getting that kind of accolades
it's like a somebody in your dreams
thank you so much
yeah
thank you
you know it's so wonderful is that they
don't seek the accolades they don't seek
the praise you can see how touched they
are but it's never ever ever too late to
say thank you and to let you know that
you're appreciated in whatever it is
that you do never yeah for every team
that i played on i told my coaches
whether it was practice game day at an
event yeah if i saw a man or woman that
serves this country or has served this
country i was going to stop everything i
was doing to send a message to the young
players that we need to show gratitude
to them so i would encourage anybody
just like you heard if you see someone
that serves this country or have served
just walk over to him and say thank you
that's it just that little bit of
gratitude means so much to them yeah you
can do it today it is veterans day it is
a day for it but you can do it every day
as they point out as well i like the
letter that said keep being amazing and
i like hearing the children's voices and
their little suckers and the handwriting
i love the handwriting shout out to you
adam a t and colby hochmet who put that
together again i say
you know we have a great team here at
cbs i know i'm a little biased but these
pieces are very difficult to do to get
the music to get the right inflection to
get the right tones to get the right
interviews well done guys well done